amelia what's up hi dr d thank you for
taking my call
thank you so much for calling what's up
so when i was
18 i just
left home okay and i just walked out
why'd you leave
um unhealthy and
toxic environment and controlling
um and so before i was just done
before you leave what does that mean was
it uh abusive
or were people just giving you mean
curfews or strict curfews what does that
mean
toxic and controlling um
like i would say verbally um
like you don't deserve this verbal put
down
um a lot of like mean comments
based on the mood of one of my parents
um so and that's been five years
um from now almost five years so
i'm wondering how i should reach out to
my family
and also if i should reach out to my mom
and
how to help her
so have you had any contact with him in
five years
um especially over the summer i started
contacting um some of my siblings and
talking about their experiences
i had a little bit of contact with my
dad
um but i haven't seen or talked to my
mom
so are you i don't really understand
what you're asking me are you asking
how do you call and reconnect with your
mom
how do you get back in touch with your
whole family what do you what do you
drill down for me what are you asking
um how do i know when it's
safe for healthy and to
like restart that relationship
does your mom have mental illness is she
well
i think she does have some sort of
mental
illness i i don't know what and it's
probably
undiagnosed and untreated okay
um you know it's safe when
you have boundaries that you firmly
established and people don't cross them
and so that's how you know you're safe
when you say i only tolerate
people in my life who talk to me
respectfully and who don't put me down
and they may tell me things i don't want
to hear that's just called
accountability that's called friends who
actually love you it's called parents
and family members who actually love you
um but they don't put me down they don't
beat me up they don't talk to me
disrespectfully
um they're honorable people to be around
and that's how you know
my heart rate doesn't get up when i
think of talking to them
i don't lose sleep knowing i have a
phone call with them tomorrow
or that i've got a coffee date with them
tomorrow
i don't always look forward to it but i
don't get you know right
my my body's alarm systems don't go off
when you talk to your dad does it still
freak you out or have you reconnected
and it's wonderful to hear his voice
again
yeah it was um super awesome to talk to
him
and it was great i i feel like i'm
missing something here why don't you
just go home and see your mom
why don't you call her and say i'm going
to be home on friday and let's go to
lunch
um
she's pretty mean okay then why don't
you just not call her
um i
well i guess i did that for the past
five years
um but i just
want to help her i guess
even though it's um it's hard to have
contact with her what do you want to
help her with
she's all alone sort of she's
burned a lot of relationships even with
her
um like
brothers and sisters um my aunt and
uncle
she's burned a lot of relationships and
i think she
really needs a lot of help so amelia
this is gonna suck
but i was gonna be honest with you okay
you can't fix your mom
you can't fix her you can love her
and you can be in relationship with her
but if she
let her 18 year old daughter walk out
the door and hasn't tried to reach out
and connect with you
and if she burned up her marriage and
her brothers and sisters
there's not a lot you can do
yeah you can go in there with some firm
boundaries and know my mom's gonna
be angry and she's gonna be mean and
she's got her own story from when she
was a kid
and she just needs someone to sit with
her and love her
and that's going to be noble like holy
work for you to go do that
but i want you to be real careful about
building a fantasy you're not going to
get back those last five years
yeah and even growing up
it wasn't a good relationship i knew
she was sort of mentally ill and
it was always quite angry um
is it okay to never
talk to her again i guess yeah if that's
what it takes to keep you safe yeah
it is
i'm i'm a big fan of never giving up on
somebody
and so if i was in your shoes i would
send a letter with the number where they
could reach me
i would probably always make sure that a
few times a year i sent something in
writing just let them know i loved them
and i hope they were doing well and
i'm also going to be about the business
of making sure that i'm safe
and i'm not in an abusive relationship
and that my kids are safe and my spouse
is safe and those kind of things
but yeah when somebody for whatever
reason
and it sounds my guess is your mom went
through some really hard crap when she
was a kid
and she got stuck in some loopty loops
and has never
been able to come out it's never chosen
to come out never done the hard work to
break some of those old old cycles
and sometimes when you get in those
cycles you treat people a way that
you wish you hadn't of instead of saying
i'm sorry and leaning into fixing that
it just compounds that it makes that
shame and depression cycle spin faster
and faster and you find yourself all
alone
and if you're struggling with mental
illness sometimes that stuff accelerates
it
or as a result of it and so
yeah if you're not safe stay away
it's not it's not your job to go back
and repair something that somebody else
broke
yeah what's your dad say
um sorry
no you're okay
um he's good he still lives with my mom
um they don't talk much i think
does he think you should call your mom
um
she agrees that it's
she's kind of a toxic person so
i i don't think he thinks it's wrong for
me to not call her
you can i lean into something real quick
amelia you keep saying
kinda and a little bit and it's just
sort of mean
you're using real minimizing language
does your mom hurt you
does she tell you that you're a loser
you're not a good daughter and
you're never grateful for any of the
stuff that she gave you
and you're a jerk and she wished you'd
never been born she stays stuff like
that to you
or does she say things like man you
whine a lot
you're a grouch like what does she say
you're using really
evasive minimizing language um
like in high school i um probably
very obviously needed to go through
counseling and the school provided that
and
she'd say things like oh you're screwed
up in the head
you don't deserve to have friends you
don't deserve to
go outside it's pretty mean stuff
hey amelia moms aren't supposed to say
that to their kids
yeah i know and that's not your fault
all right left
amelia that's not your fault
you're not hearing me that's not your
fault
kids are supposed to have friends and
they are supposed to go outside
and they're supposed to be hugged and
loved
i'm sorry you didn't get that
thank you
and so yeah if your mom's not well if
she's not healthy
and she's going to hurt you again um
it's probably not smart or safe for you
to head back in there unless you've got
some real strong boundaries
and you've probably got some training
you've probably got a counselor that's
working with you
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
fix your mom that's her work to do
and you're probably maybe it always
works this way in the movies but not a
lot in real life
you're probably not going to get an
apology from her
yeah i
yeah and hey
emilia you deserve one but you're
probably not gonna get it
and so grieving that loss putting that
down that fantasy down that myth down
that
my mom's gonna circle back around and be
the mom like my friends had
it's probably not gonna happen
and i hate that for you
do your brothers and sisters still keep
up with her
um i have one sister that
probably hasn't talked to her since
seven or eight years
and a younger sister that'll call and
touch me
yeah amelia there's just a family
pattern here
it's time to let it go
it's time to let her go
and if your dad's a good man and he's
standing by her
and trying to be the best husband he can
be for sickness and in health
then good for him and keep connected to
him
and keep connected to your sisters
but yeah you got to put that one down
and you can still love her you can love
the idea of her
but you're not going to get that one
back and you're not going to fix that
one
and i'm sorry to tell you that i know
it's heartbreaking
i cannot recommend enough that you get
somebody whether it's a minister or a
friend that you can be vulnerable with
or a group
there in your community or a counselor
someone you could walk alongside for a
short time
just to help process and grieve this
properly
and then yeah set it down and that's so
hard you sat down your freaking mom
she set you down man and she obviously
had some stuff in her heart that just
made her bitter against the world and
who knows what her story is and i bet
it's traumatic and hard too
but that's not for you to fix or solve
so i'm sorry that she hurt you i wish i
had better news for emilia but yeah you
gotta put that one down
thank you so much for trusting me with
that call for being vulnerable
that was a hard one